people have been in we fight we dare we
and that my friends is how a revolution
dies if you're a fan of the hunger games
then you know that the four blockbuster
films dealt with some heavy dark and at
more than one time
heartbreaking subject matter so you'd
think that the set would be just as
serious
right well not exactly by all accounts
the hunger games set was known to be a
dynamic playful and cheerful
place despite the dark dystopian
realities of pan m
today we're bringing you the best behind
the scenes moments of this
wickedly talented set including which
tributes pulled off the best pranks
who gave josh hutcherson a bad
concussion and why jennifer lawrence is
according to liam hemsworth somehow the
best and
also the worst actor to work with on set
my smile is so ingenuine people are
going to think that i hate it
despite being love interest on screen
jennifer lawrence and josh hutcherson
were nothing but
absolute pals off screen by all accounts
fellow actors producers and
other personnel could not help but
mention how despite their character's
serious and dramatic storylines these
two could not stop joking around with
each other up until the camera started
rolling
you'd think that the director and his
team would be super annoyed with two
kids fooling around on set
but these two were anything but
unprofessional as soon as the director
yelled
tracking with the three year difference
between the two jennifer and josh
clearly had a big sister little brother
vibe while filming the hunger games
movies
watch these behind the scenes outtakes
of the two chasing and
pushing each other between takes and
don't for a second think that these
feelings expressed by josh weren't
mutual
in this outtake jennifer is literally
pushing him around like a big sister
with a little brother
when you consider how close these two
were it's easy to understand why these
two had such an electric on-screen
chemistry
not to mention seeing these two stars
have fun on the job must have inspired
others on set to not take their job
too seriously one of the most intense
scenes of the four movies is when josh's
character starts to go into a manic in
the mockingjay
on-screen peta looks like he's inches
away from taking away katniss's life
but in real life apparently the scene
was extremely difficult to take without
one or
the other bursting into laughter
watch this hilarious outtake of jennifer
and josh pretending to be cats between
takes to cut the tension of an
otherwise dark and violent scene and
then maybe
we have a shot of being friends
according to sources the hunger games
set was a major prank war between actors
not surprisingly jennifer is probably
the one who started it all when she
accidentally gave josh a minor
concussion while training for a combat
scene on set i kicked him in the head
by accident apparently the only fitting
way josh thought he could get even with
his co-star was to sneak glimmers body
double
into jen's trailer the dummy thing had
me for a little bit listen to these
snippets
on how the prank went down he put a dead
dummy on my toilet holding toilet paper
and scared me
so when she opened up her bathroom to go
to the bathroom she saw a
rotting human being the prank scared jen
so much that there's a circulating rumor
that she even peed her pants with how
terrified she was
sources tell me that she actually peed
her pants i i didn't see it for fact
this just goes to show that you
shouldn't mess with either of these
young actors unless you're ready to be
injured or
downright petrified i just like to keep
a set fun
speaking of pranks other actors took it
upon themselves to put the prank and
joke's queen jennifer in her place
actor jeffrey wright who plays bt in
mockingjay famously gifted his young
co-star a beautiful tiffany box only to
find it full of live crickets
since she opened it in her trailer
jennifer was reported to have spent
weeks trying to get them all out won't
be replicated very easily
jennifer's other co-star liam hemsworth
has also said that working on set was an
absolute blast to the point where it
didn't feel like
work but of course the two being best
friends offset
found it awkward to muster up that
intimate energy for an
on-screen kiss in an interview the actor
revealed that the most awkward scenes to
shoot on set were
any kissing scenes with his co-star
anytime i had to kiss jennifer was
pretty uncomfortable
but don't get it twisted it had nothing
to do with the fact that they weren't
professionals
rather it was because jennifer would
choose specifically what she would eat
for lunch
right before they locked lips she'd be
like yeah i had tuna i had garlic and i
didn't brush my teeth
outside of the katniss peta and gale
love triangle jennifer
also had great relationships with the
other actors on set
one of our favorite on and off screen
dynamics is between jen and the youngest
actor on set
amanda stenberg who played roo jennifer
was really she was great to work with
their chemistry on screen was
absolutely electric and from these
outtakes we can see why
channeling her big sister energy to the
youngest actor on this set
makes us feel all warm and tingly inside
their stuff who wouldn't be crazy
fans will not forget the epic and
unforgettable scene in which katniss is
having her last conversation with roo
after she died protecting the tribute
from district 13.
and while this scene had audiences
everywhere tearing up this tribute says
that apparently jen had this crazy habit
of telling hilarious and inappropriate
jokes right before the director yells
action hey remind me to tell you this
really funny fart joke when this is over
action oh my god although she may look
innocent and harmless amanda was amongst
the most deviant pranksters on the set
of the first hunger games film
alongside another tribute jacqueline
emerson also known as fox face
madeline jackie those two are like the
dynamic duo of pranks okay
this dynamic duo even left a signature
on a posted note every time they pulled
off a prank
their signature prank was stealing the
other actors clothes or even putting
them in the refrigerator
like a note on my mirror that's like
wear your pants jack you'll never find
them
probably the most epic prank pulled off
by these young actresses
involved high school girls a stalker
scare jack quaid who played marvel in
the first film
and alexander ludwig who played cato
because the tributes were shooting off
location they all bunked up in a hotel
close by
so naturally amanda and jaclyn pulled
off some major pranks on their fellow
actors
because that's what you do when you're
hanging out with all of your friends
this prank got so intense that
apparently jack really thought he had a
group of fan girl stalkers on his tail
of course once he found out that this
was all staged he knew
exactly who was behind this epic prank
i battled them it was i i can see the
war
by now you've probably realized that
although they were out to kill each
other in the first flick the actors who
played the tributes in real life
actually liked each other at the end of
every filming day the gang would hang
out
have dance parties and even eat sushi
just check out this clip of the crew
playing ninja between takes on location
no i totally got you it's adventure
singing in the van
and just being silly teens on set
goddamn so hungry
elizabeth banks who plays effie trinket
in the films has by all means the
wackiest
and most performative wardrobe on the
hunger games set
and while we thought she would have
loved dressing to the nines throughout
the films apparently her outfits
prevented her from being candid and
letting loose because of how heavy and
campy they were
i'm stuck in this in this all day long
there's no
question that pan am fashion is
avant-garde to say the least
and while elizabeth banks or effie was
used to it jennifer expressed that it
was difficult for her at times to
channel this feminine part of herself
check out this behind-the-scenes outtake
of jen expressing how she
actually had a nightmare about being in
a big dress in front of a room full of
people
i had this dream that i was in this
ridiculous dress in front of hundreds of
people i don't know
and i just spin around like an idiot
we'll never forget that first scene when
all the tributes are in their arena
it's arguably one of the most dramatic
and intense scenes of the whole movie
and with good reason each person needed
to fight each other to the death for a
chance to get some of the best survival
gear in order to get the best chance of
winning the games
while the scene was beautifully
choreographed what we don't see is how
hot it was that day when the actors were
shooting that famous clip
shout out to juliana for making these
coats so hot shooting on location is
always tricky business and so to combat
the heat jennifer apparently spent much
of her time between takes with her pants
around her ankles
and just having my pants around my
ankles outside i was like i don't even
care anymore
i don't care there's no question that
the hunger games film put amanda on the
map
her role in the first film completely
catapulted her career
you may have recognized her from the big
blockbuster hit the hate u give
but that doesn't mean she has forgotten
her roots and where it all started
in an interview with jimmy fallon on the
tonight show amanda revealed that
jennifer lawrence was a mentor to her
on the set of the hunger games in many
ways
aside from mentoring the young actress
she also very practically taught amanda
how to pee in the woods
what did you learn from jennifer
lawrence um she taught me how to pee in
the woods
so what's your favorite outtake or
behind the scenes blooper
would you have liked to be a part of
this film let us know in the comments
below and for
more videos on your favorite films
subscribe to the things